we're talking like highly intelligent
and your gap or just everywhere I know
almost like I wanted you to mention that
there rubber in shady news oh my god
another tiny science not damn it
submitted by JK best a cook at a caviar
and champagne bar was fired because he
called his bosses out on serving rotten
eggs so which one is shady the guy who
ratted them out or the pawn it doesn't
good boss I think it's the ball I think
it's the boss - nah but the snitches
don't get the riches when they get the
stitches yep so you shouldn't be a
snitch so they're just like double shade
shady [ __ ] yeah I understand two
shades darker
this is gray dawn gray and he used to be
a chef at this place
not the airport - yeah you guys know
what a talent that's the International a
lot of caviar I've never seen quest
because I've been there I've never you a
rotten egg dude in what terminal is this
gnarly right the International on and
that's why by the end of this hearing
yet so the boss is trying to [ __ ] you
and serve spoiled quail eggs I think
it's there and then in the middle
there's like a bar and at the other end
it's like a flower or restaurant or
something like that not father like a
like a sushi restaurant or whatever
oh so Donald Grey was forced to eat
these expired caviar tours to eat yes to
make sure that it was a good quality to
actually serve it to the customer oh my
god and so like because he actually like
tasted the caviar and like see how fresh
it was like it wasn't fresh at all
because when he got home um he actually
got food poisoning oh my god and so then
when you complained to the bosses like
hey you know like you can't do anything
like this because apparently the bosses
would actually order like the chef and
other employees here to like rip off the
sell-by date all in my pajamas
that's like at all ready man what ha ha
I mean but if you look at it from the
owners perspective these people are just
flying out of the states anyway so how
they gonna get caught that's like one
thing again like if you just blame it on
the airplane food I can see why they do
it
not that it's right yeah yeah I think
it's [ __ ] up the worst but I can see
why they're doing it because it's like
these people are leaving the country
oh kidding Oh we bought the Chettiar
whiskey after he brought it up to the
higher-ups like hey I got food poisoning
from eating that like nasty caviar they
actually just discipline him instead and
they expect you to win oh yeah and I
pull down your pants Oh bad boy you got
food poisoning
yeah discipline them and then eventually
he got fired yeah that seems like
grounds for a lawsuit for sure
absolutely yeah
and so now like he's having a lawsuit up
against them for unlawful termination
that's a [ __ ] [ __ ] after after he was
like telling his bosses like hey you
know this caviar isn't good anymore like
we should probably cost this and maybe
we shouldn't like peel off like these
dates you know he's going to need all
the employees in testifiers yeah I don't
want to lose their jobs
yeah I know I was just his word that
Satan is still into operations to my
knowledge yes Oh Jesse well that's
because they always have international
customers and international customers
won't come back on Yelp here's more
pictures of his while he's going fishing
now fired
this is he's going is a camper now he
likes to go can you just like unemployed
what the I saw like a bee on that tricep
right there oh damn I didn't know caviar
have so much protein had you guys tried
caviar no I think I have the little
little black things right yeah yeah yeah
what do you eat it with crackers I think
I think you just eat it with your pinkie
open it you asked if I can do I think
it's really salty only an acquired taste
so is it like one of those things will
you pair it with an alcoholic drink or
whatever whatever or is it just like a
champagne yeah like a weekend brunch
snack or whatever I don't think it's
crunchy okay yeah okay you eat it out of
like I think it's occasional yeah I
think I I eat it superfood yeah yes
like the actual taste buds acquired for
it where it's at all its bomb but it
doesn't taste that so I just eat it I
don't really know like why people like
it is it like super expensive why is it
so I heard it was expensive as garbage
like it's like this [ __ ] little and
you're like oh my god you paid that much
so it's it so I just looked up on how to
eat caviar and so it says open your
mouth good
well so step one is know what you're
eating
learn what caviar is so that eating
caviar will be less daunting caviar is
the eggs of a female fish traditionally
coming from virgin yeah
today more affordable caviar is made
from salmon and American paddlefish okay
number two keep it cold okay number
three use the right utensils caviar
should never be served on steel or
stainless steel plates or fork as this
can change the taste of the caviar I
made it bitter or metallic eat and serve
caviar wood utensils a ceramic glass or
plastic to perversities I like the idea
of plastic with caviar it's the
dichotomy of really bougie and Jeff
you're really nice classy
Nick you're like a salt alright cut
number four try several kinds number
five cake small bites caviar should be
served and consumed an amount smaller
than a tablespoon an anonymous [ __ ] any
time I read cab you lies because I
ordered something else and the chef is
trying to be Fanta made like buckets
sprinkle it I try to Scott - is down as
fast as I can
I have no idea it is traditional
etiquette to eat caviar in small bites
and if you're just learning to eat it
small bites will healthy experience if
we were more completely without becoming
overwhelmed by the flavor or maybe not
sounds not enough it's all game number
six is eating with crackers seven you
garnish it eight consume or serve the
entire container nine use it as an
advertiser intent just finishing life
appetizer caviar 101 yeah yeah yeah I
learned a lot that's so I think is very
useful information for a long time but
oh yeah keep that in mind when I go to
McDonald's yeah I meant to be a peasant
because
but none of this [ __ ] made me go Oh
caviar let me try it I want to be losing
watch I love it
it's rescript references I'm really glad
I've never really worked on being like
the food industry to see health foods
press because it is I am NOT like the
biggest fan of food and if I saw [ __ ]
was getting made I'd be like that's a
pen so my dad had restaurant an icicle
vision was a kid and I saw big-ass
rafters that did bother me you saw big
around I mean like prop oh I'm not a -
y'all know that's just a Dan tipping hey
bite your shoulder like it's good luck
yeah like it was always there's a bad
look I just remember that when I worked
at a restaurant I felt like a whole
bunch of food leftover I just felt so
bad that we had to like toss it out and
like we even mentioned it over to the
managers like oh why can't we just like
safety food or like to your home a
shelter or something and they're like
well it's a liability because if people
get like it's a homeless people get sick
from eating our foods and they can go
ahead and do us for that it's like very
true yeah when I used to work at a
restaurant that's where I won like this
because I would just eat it yeah one
thing I can say this now because I don't
work there anymore about which
restaurant was this oh all the
restaurants I worked at a circus in the
Frasers and the walk-in fridge um in the
bathroom I like to stick it in my apron
I take like you would take Megan wings
and put them in your apron that's cool
you did it I'm just trying to play that
out like the chicken when you've got
like sauce on and you're down just
owning like a cloth apron this is kind
of like really desperate naked wings
from the freezer so they work why were
you that hungry
you cook there that hole is not out
right so they were frozen cause I'm real
impressed right now yeah I've actually
superheroes I just breathes on it I cook
it and then I eat it no it's they cook
it already a lot of restaurants that you
go to the food isn't fresh so especially
if it's like a chain restaurant like a
Chili's or TGI Fridays no I'm on a bus
which one is it
I was I was working Elephant Bar which
is neither one of them but so they'll
fry the chicken and then they'll put it
in the walk-in until people order it
then they toss it in the buffalo sauce
and cook it again it's common for a lot
of restaurants right so I would take it
before is in the sauce and the walk-in
put some drumsticks and wear apron go
the good old bathroom scarf me down
before it was just cold it was cooked
cold chicken yes what how do you eat
when you smell [ __ ] the bathrooms didn't
smell that bad like okay look so good I
don't know or the chicken must have
smelled real yeah tell em you had to do
some double-oh-seven like a I just asked
the cook to make me a plate really like
can you meet money I would just realize
we homework you scare me we really yeah
just be like I'm hungry every I what
everyone was doing it doesn't count me
old for you know restaurant when I was
the driver of BJ's I did delivery for
like the most bougie pizza company any
time that food was not picked up in the
to go area like it was claimed so I'll
take that and also just throw it in my
car and then just you know heart but now
mutilator because I don't know if you're
working at a restaurant like that
chances are they're going to go to me
all the time I was a cocktail waitress
for like a hot minute and night we would
have designated areas that only like the
staff news event like we would tell the
cook like hey we're hungry yeah so you
would just leave it in that area eat
there but that's I feel like that's
super common but that didn't happen with
you
oh well that did have a Mickey I just
take extra for just extra hungry side
yes
you just had it for the freaking cold
chicken it was just like the thing ya
seen in for it so you like ugly guys and
cold fried food get there together I'm
already here dang and dreams yeah you're
like follower list is just growing it's
gonna be like 10 million baht I'm Gong
yeah welcome the DMS are gonna be
growing perfect hopefully one of them
can bring over some cold chicken so I
wanted my Wow
hey guys I hope you enjoyed that episode
of just getting news and if you guys
want to share a story there's a link
down in the description box below we can
submit your story if you guys want to
watch more episodes click right up here
[Music]